[تصفيق]
هاي ازيكم
في الصوره دي كنت لسه واخده بطوله افريقيا
للمره الثالثه ليا
وكانت تعتبر من اهم واحلى البطولات
بالنسبه لي
ودي وانا في اولمبياد طوكيو 2021 كانت
المشاركه الثالثه ليا برضو في الاولمبياد
وساعتها انا وصلت لدور 32
ودي تعتبر افضل نتيجه لاي بنت مصريه
وافريقيه في تاريخ الحمد لله
ودي بعد ما تم اختياري من ضمن اكتر 30
شخصيه مؤثره تحت سن الثلاثين تبع مجله
فورس ميدل ايست طبعا دي كانت تعتبر حاجه
كبيره جدا بالنسبه لي برضو
ده الفيديو وانا بستلم
سي وان
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله انا في كل اللحظات اللي فاتت دي
كنت مبسوطه جدا جدا وكانت كلها لحظات حلوه
قوي بالنسبه لي
بس الحقيقه بقى انه ورا كل لحظه من دول
كان في لحظات تانيه صعبه جدا جدا ومختلفه
ناس كتير بتفتكر ان الوصول للاتشيفنت او
لحاجه حلوه قوي بيكون سهل بس الحقيقه طبعا
الطريق ده بيكون مليان شالنجرز ومليان
تحديات لازم الواحد يتخطاها عشان يعرف
الاخر يوصل للبطوله كبير بس هي الناس
بتشوف اللقطه الاخيره بس ما بيكونوش
شايفين الصوره كامله على بعض
النهارده انا عايزه اقسم التشالنجرز دي او
التاس مومنتس دي لتلات حاجات اساسيه اول
حاجه هي الساكرب او التضحيات اللي لازم
الواحد يعملها علشان في الاخر يوصل لحاجه
حلوه
ثاني حاجه هي
الواحد يخرج بره دايره الراحه بتاعته
وتالت حاجه هي ازاي الواحد يتعامل مع
الخساره واللحظات الصعبه اللي بتيجي بعد
الخساره
اول حاجه هتكلم عنها هي
انا رحلتي مع الرياضه بدات وانا عندي
تقريبا سبع سنين ومن هنا بدات اكون كميه
بمواعيد تمارين معينه ولازم ان انا طبعا
التزم بها ان انا برضو كنت مهتميه جدا
بجانب الدراسي واهلي كانوا مهتمين ان انا
اكون شاطره في المدرسه واهتم بالاتنين مع
بعض فعشان اقدر اوفق ما بين الدراسه
والرياضه مع بعض كان لازم طبعا ان انا
اضحي بحاجه ثالثه والحاجه دي هي كانت الفن
او وقت الترفيه يعني مثلا انا خروجاتي
عموما هي اقل بكتير من مثلا بقيه صحابي
الاجازات عموما اقل السفريات المصايف
وهكذا
[موسيقى]
بس في الاخر بعد ما الواحد بيبدا ان هو
يحقق ويوصل لحاجه حلوه بيحس انه الست دي
كانت يعني اكيد اوف في الاخر وكانت تستاهل
فعلا ان الواحد يعملها
تاني حاجه بقى
هيون
واكثر اجزام في الحته دي هو معسكرات الصين
اللي يعرف منكم الصين هم اكتر ناس
ضمينيتنج في لعبتنا زي ما انتم شايفين
يعني
الاربعه وهم كمان يقدروا مثلا لحد اول 50
كمان لو هم عايزين لان هم فعلا اجمد ناس
في لعبه
فبالتالي انا قررت انه يعني افضل مكان ان
انا اطلع معسكرات فيه هو الصين
ودي مش حاجه سهله خالص لانه الصين اولا
بلد بعيده عننا
انه هم ناس مختلفه جدا عننا
بتاعتهم مختلفه ما بيتكلموش انجلش فهناك
الموضوع فعلا بيكون صعب قوي
بلس بردو انه التمرين بتاعهم بيكون فيري
انتانس مش سهله خالص يعني طول اليوم
تقريبا بيتمرنوا فدي حاجه ما كانتش سهله
فانا اكيد كان اريح لي ان انا مثلا افضل
في مصر اتمرن في وسط في بلدي وابقى مع
عيلتي في البيت واتمرن مع الناس اللي انا
عارفاها سواء في النادي بتاعي او في
المنتخب
بس انا اخترت ان انا اعمل الحاجه دي حتى
لو هي مش مريحه قوي بالنسبه لي عشان في
الاخر يكون في نتيجه افضل وطبعا الحمد لله
معسكرات الصين كلها كانت سرقه جدا جدا
معايا وكانت سبب اكيد كبير في ان انا
اوصل الحمد لله النتائج كويسه
ثالث حاجه بقى هي اللاصق وازاي الواحد
يقدر يتعامل مع الخساره واللحظات الصعبه
قوي اللي بتيجي بعدها
الرياضه طبعا زي ما انتم عارفين فيها
المكسب وفيها الخساره ما فيش حد بيفضل
يكسب على طول زي الحياه بالظبط الحياه
فيها الداونز بس انا بشوف انه اللي بيفرق
شخص عن التاني هو ازاي بيتعامل في الاوقات
الصعبه دي وازاي بيتعمل مع الخساره
هل هو هيقرر انها تكون بريمنت ويوقف لحد
هنا وما يكملش ولا هيختار انها تكون حاجه
مؤقته او ويحاول ان هو يغيرها ويحولها من
خساره المكسب
انا عن نفسي في الكارير بتاعي اقدر اقول
انه الحمد لله
اكتر خسارات كانت صعبه بالنسبه لي كانت
بعد كده
سبب في اكبر الحمد لله
يعني مثلا هقول لك
انا سنه 20 21
خسرت بطوله افريقيا
وبعدها بكام شهر برضه في 2022
خسرت كاس افريقيا وده كان بعد ما انا كان
بقى لي تقريبا ست سبع سنين الحمد لله باخذ
كل الافريقي ايفنس اللي انا بلعبها
فساعتها الخساره دي كانت فعلا صعبه قوي
عليا لانه لما حد بيفضل يكسب فتره طويله
وبعد كده بيخسر دي مش حاجه بتكون سهله
بيبقى شويه وناس كثير بتبدا تجناس كتير
بتبدا تتكلم معه هو ايه اللي حصل فيه ايه
فما بيبقاش موقف سهل
بس ساعتها انا الحمد لله طبعا برضه
بمساعده اهلي كمان هم اللي شجعوني ان انا
اكمل في التمرين وما اقفش وبلا كمان كان
عندي موتيفيشن عالي جدا ودي برده تعتبر من
ضمن المزايا اللي واحد ممكن يستغل لها لما
بيخسر ان هو ان هي بتعلي جدا جواه ان هو
عايز يغير الوضع اللي هو فيه ده
فبالتالي بيبقى عندي موتوريشن ان انا اكمل
اكتر في التمرين واسعه واجي على نفسي اكثر
فالحمد لله بعدها باربع شهور بس قدرت ان
انا
اكسب بطوله افريقيا في سبتمبر 2022 اللي
هي كانت اول صوره خالص
فهنا اقدر اقول ان الخساره دي كانت زي
نعمه من عند ربنا ليا وكانت سبب بعد كده
مهم بالنسبه لي بلس كمان انه في نفس
الفتره الحمد لله قدرت ان انا اكسب ماتشين
من اصعب الماتشات يعني بنت من شاينيستايبي
وبنت من هونغ كونج
والبنتين دول انا عمري في حياتي ما كنت
سبتهم قبل كده بلاعبهم ان انا عندي 15 سنه
وكانت اول مره اكسبهم اكشن بعد الفتره
اللي هي اللي انا مريت بالخساره فيها
زي ما قلت لكم يعني الخساره ساعات ممكن
تبقى فعلا نعمه من عند ربنا وبعد كده يجي
بعدها اكيد من كثير
فان كونوشن عايزه اقول لكل حد
لو انتوا بتمروا بوقت صعب وايا كان
الكارير بتاعكم
لو الكارير ده مثلا في تشالنجر كتير
بتقابلكم وحاسين انه فعلا الوقت صعب خلي
عندك ايمان من جواك انه ان شاء الله
بالاجتهاد طبعا في الطريق الصح
وبالصبر ان شاء الله في حاجات كتير قوي
حلوه هتيجي
[تصفيق]